[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and i'm
going to be hosting the ramsey show
today with my good friend george camel
host of the fine print podcast you can
give us a call because we are here for
you triple eight eight two five
five two two five of course as always
we're taking your calls on money
business
life relationships or if you just want
to
uh i don't know run a decision by us ask
for some advice
uh you know get some feedback we're here
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and george i'm excited
about this i'm excited because i get
toast with you i'm excited because it's
fun friday those are both great things
and it's a holiday friday kicking off a
holiday weekend of halloween uh this
morning was was quite an adventure
getting my kids out the door for school
because today the friday before
halloween typically there's halloween
parties at school and so you've got to
get the costumes and get the treat bags
and get all the things you volunteered
for three weeks ago to bring for the
halloween party and remember those
things oh my god i cannot imagine and i
heard a rumor that all three of your
little ones will be here in just a few
short hours well so here at the office
from four to six we do a ramsey
trick-or-treating for all of our ramsey
team members and families and kids and
it is
absolutely chaotic and hilarious and so
much fun i'm just going for the
entertainment can we just can we talk
about what carter was last year
this many people may not know this but
y'all my son is a big fan of waffle
house
and so when halloween rolled around
he informed me he wanted to be waffle
house
a server no
the building the waffle house building
so george you know i love a good
challenge and you know i'm creative
please tell me you recreated the waffle
house building as a costume i did i did
and it was next level let me tell you
how next level it was to make the
windows of the waffle house building
that is around his body i took him to
waffle house put him in a booth and took
pictures of him outside printed those
pictures and then put them on the
outside of the building so it really
looked like he was i'm telling you that
is so next level here's what here's my
favorite part though so carter goes
trick-or-treating here at our office and
all around for that matter
and he when he goes to waffle house he
only gets a waffle that's all he's ever
gotten is all he likes that's all he
knows is there potentially right in the
name he was very confused when
everywhere he went people started
shouting their hashbrown orders at him
scattered covered and smothered he's
like
he's just so oh no poor buddy he was so
confused why everyone is shouting these
words at him he's never eaten those in
his life he had no idea
anyway if you are a celebrating
halloween i hope you guys have a safe
and fun halloween hopefully you had a
easier halloween costume than i had last
year this year we did amazon orders it
was three little pigs and it was easy
you have taken back your time you took
your own advice christy like i'm not
spending 16 hours on a waffle house
nope and if he comes up with something
weird again let's be honest i'll get
sucked right back and do it
because i love i love the challenge but
we're here for you we're taking your
calls we're having fun today we are
excited to hang out with you as always
we love answering your questions and
love hearing your stories um you know
some of you guys have some amazing
testimonies of becoming debt free or
making it to the next baby step and we
just want to cheer you on because this
is such an opportunity to
celebrate that progress because you're
going to inspire someone else that's
making progress so give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we're gonna kick off today with
danielle in new york city new york hey
danielle how are you
danielle are you there for me
oh danielle are you there let's try one
last time
oh daniel's i was so excited we'll get
there we'll get there
maybe maybe we've got a sticky button
situation
there we go
hey
sorry i don't know what happened there
it's not just fun friday it's weird
friday the weird the board's not working
it's spooky friday that's right what's
going on how are you
i'm great christy and and george thank
you for taking my call
happy friday to you both yeah you too
what's going on um
all right well i'm calling because i
would love to hear your thoughts words
of wisdom on
my financial situation
my husband and i we are proud to be
debt-free congratulations
thank you we
have paid off our home our college loans
we live in a one-bedroom apartment
that's um we own it in in new york city
um but we have a daughter and we want to
buy a house um we're saving because we
would like to buy that in cash and
right now we have
quite a bit in savings
but we're not going to buy the house for
another two to three years so i'm
wondering what we can do with that large
amount of savings we have to hopefully
grow it in the next couple years so we
have more to buy that house yeah i've
got a couple follow-up questions before
i know george wants to jump in here but
new york housing is so expensive and so
i can't even ballpark what your budget
is give us some details on what is your
savings account now and what's your goal
to be able to buy this house taking into
consideration if you sell your current
apartment and that type of thing
yes christy you uh hit the nail on the
head with that the new york
housing is astronomically expensive and
so right now in savings we have six
hundred thousand oh that's amazing yeah
thank you and i know in new york money
that is also like
only goes so far
yes and
we 600 000 in cash gets you at best at
best a fixer-upper um you know in in new
york city so we're hoping that we'd be
able to buy something
closer to the dollar you know just under
a million dollars um
in the next three years i would say um
so
just wondering how we best use that six
hundred thousand dollars now rather than
having it sit in a savings account while
we wait to buy a house are you going to
sell your current place
you know that's the other question we're
considering either selling it or keeping
it and renting it out as a rental
property then we have the passive income
gotcha what's it worth out of curiosity
roughly i would say
350
000. okay
cool
awesome so between your cash that you
have right now and the value of your
home you have almost a million dollars
correct
yeah that is correct
okay so well this just tells me that you
have options because let's say two years
from now you're like we really want to
get into this house but the savings in
the bank isn't there well we can sell
ours and then use all of that money plus
the money we have saved and be able to
do that so i just like having options
same so that's a great starting point
how much could you guys save
in a year if you just stash money away
in your savings account what would that
amount to in a year
great question i should know the answer
to this uh we we have a pretty solid
income um so
i'd say we we have an income of about
300 000. awesome combined between my
husband and i uh we do have a daughter
who's in daycare and and those types of
things right now so you could throw
probably a hundred grand in savings each
year easily yeah okay so if i'm you guys
i mean with a two-year horizon it's too
short for me to be throwing it into the
stock market mutual funds if you're
talking about three to five years plus
then that's when i would go all right
let's get these in mutual funds index
funds and you can work with one of our
smart investor pros if you don't have
one these are investing pros that you
can trust to do things the ramsey way
they have the heart of a teacher that
can help your money grow at maybe you
know 10 11
so but beyond that if it's under that
i'm parking it in some high yield
savings accounts making a half percent
not super sexy but safe yeah and you're
doing amazing danielle you're doing
amazing the fact that you have that much
money in savings even in the new york
market you're doing incredible so well
done thanks for calling thank you this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter dot
com slash ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me is my
good friend and host of the fine print
podcast george camel and we are taking
your calls here on the ramsay show today
it's fun friday everybody is excited
it's friday and we are here to talk to
you triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you have a question
about money life business whatever you
wanna talk about we are here for you
we're going to go to charleston south
carolina with patrick hey patrick how
are you
hey guys i'm really appreciating y'all
taking my call sure what's going on
so i'm about to be a student in college
i'm going towards my third year
i've saved up around 151 000 through
doing stocks i'm not in debt or anything
like that um i have a vehicle
and my question is should i buy a condo
because i saw one mess on foreclosure
for roughly fifty thousand dollars
and um its estimated value is around 170
and i've been thinking about it living
um in there for about two years
and i'm having it be paid off by the end
of my
degree program so that i will save money
on housing and not have to worry about
extra housing costs while i'm in college
and um so i can get a head start on a
career as soon as i finish
yeah
okay so i just want to recap what you
said to make sure i'm getting all the
pieces right you're debt free
yes ma'am okay and you want to live in
charleston um after graduating as as of
now that you know
um i honestly have no idea where i want
to live or relocate i graduated high
school from overseas so i'm fairly new
to the united states so i'm still um
planning my life and
trying to figure out what's the best uh
next move forward yeah this is an
interesting one george i don't know what
are your thoughts i mean first of all
patrick you are you've done very well
150k
and being college
and uh do you know what you want to do
after you graduate
so i'm still kind of contemplating that
um at the moment i've just been all over
the place i've been trying to get into
the army i've been trying to get into
the navy
um also um the course i'm headed off
right now is uh psychology route maybe
becoming a psychiatrist
but there's just so many options out
there that i'm having a really hard time
just choosing uh but one thing for sure
is that i really want to get into real
estate
i've been really close to getting my
license um however just from
third-party issues i wasn't really able
to have it acquired um
just right this time so i'm thinking
about that towards more in the future
wow so a lot a lot of things you may
want to do in the future and you
mentioned that you're looking at buying
a foreclosure and for your first home
the only thing that worries me with that
is it can be a nightmare especially
while you're in school and i don't know
what the you know if it's a fixer-upper
type situation or what state that
foreclosure is in but to sign up for
that while you're trying to get through
school just it feels to me like that's a
lot i'm getting a little anxiety
thinking about it well that's that's
what i'm kind of wrestling through this
as you're talking and you're giving us
the details here patrick because
financially
you could right like you could the
numbers are there but but money
decisions aren't always just money like
we've got to look at other things and
the thing that concerns me are there's a
lot of unknowns in this we don't know
how long we're going to live in
charleston you don't know what you want
to do
you don't know the details of this
foreclosure that i hear and so it feels
like with you being young and being in
school that's a big risk and time
commitment to take on
even though you technically could do it
from a financial standpoint and so i
just i don't know i lean towards no i
don't i don't know georgetown on top of
that you mentioned the 151 000 are in
stocks and that also worries me just
because of the the volatility and the
risk there that you're taking with a lot
of money that could be used to really
catapult your future once you graduate
so here if i'm in your shoes you call
the ramsey show and these are our
principles here's what i'm doing i'm
going to cash out those stocks and put
it in a good
savings account maybe a high-yield
savings account so that when you
graduate you still have 150 000 that you
can use and you can keep saving up if
you can do that uh two really set you up
after graduation and then if you don't
want to be in charleston you can go buy
a place somewhere else and you've got a
big pile of money to do that with yeah i
think that the biggest thing to keep in
mind patrick even as we're talking to
you and thinking this through out loud
with you is just your season of life and
the unknowns and this i mean you're new
to the united states in addition to all
of this there's just a lot you don't
know and i think it's worth it to
rent which is very low risk low cost you
know what what you're paying in rent for
a couple years until you just get some
more information about where you want to
be and what you want to do and and i
have no doubt that you will get into
real estate i have no doubt you'll be
successful in real estate you're
incredibly ambitious you can tell
already with how you're doing and the
questions you're asking you're going to
do really well and you're going to do
really well financially so this is not a
step back for you it's just i think a
step of wisdom wisdom before you make
the home purchase commitment
taken into consideration all those other
factors but but great job you've done
awesome that's really really really
impressive
all right let's go to cookeville
tennessee with robert hey robert how are
you
how are you guys doing good what's going
on
oh i just wanted to call in and say
thank you for your hard work i've been
listening to the show for probably 10
years or so
and uh there's hope for people out there
that are only making about 40 000
dollars a year yeah they're a school
teacher
yeah i'm a school teacher i'm debt free
and i'm i'm about a half a millionaire
okay robert
i've already got the kids college taken
care of
and
the the ability
to give
is
you know if you're not giving you're not
living and
the the grass feels so much better in
between my toes
and you don't have to give hundreds of
thousands of dollars away to have that
good feeling
one of the best things that my family
and i do when i have my kids with me
we'll buy the car behind us in the drive
through their dinner yeah
and
like another example uh the cafeteria
staff i said i'm a school teacher and
the cafeteria staff i just bought all of
them uh coupons the other day to for
them to go out to have dinner
and just the feeling
that a person gets
from being able to do that versus having
to worry about your bills each month
uh i just thought it might be
encouraging for some people out there
listening robert i'm so glad you called
because sometimes having hearing from
someone who's actually done it who's
actually doing it that is not one of us
that does this every day representing
our company can be more powerful than
hearing from us and i just i love that
you called in i love that you are doing
it tell me tell me this what would you
say robert
to someone listening right now
and they're like well
that works for some people
that works for some people that have a
lot of money well that works for you
know and they are they are counting
themselves out of the principles the
baby steps the possibilities for the
future or ever giving like you're
talking about in big ways or small ways
talk to them robert what would you say
to someone that just doesn't believe
it's possible for people that just don't
make really big incomes
well
you just one of the keys is
you have to realize that you need to
keep your life pretty simple
simple is sweet
and live below your means
i cut my own hair i've cut my own hair
since i was 18 years old
that is impressive
i've saved a ton of money by doing my
own maintenance around the house i do my
own maintenance on my cars
things of that nature yeah
just you can you can shave you can save
and as soon as you see a little bit of
money going in the right direction it
just it just empowers you to do more and
more that is so cool i'm curious robert
how'd you get connected with us 10 years
ago
i was working at the local university
and traveling around in uh two different
locations and just got hooked on your
show when i was in the car that's
awesome were you already i just
go ahead go ahead
were you already living debt-free and
kind of a saver before that or did that
kind of set you on that path
i've had an opportunity to make quite a
bit of money in my life early on
and
no i was in debt i had college loans i
had
uh consumer debt and things of that
nature
and i just realized that it was just not
the way that i wanted to live my life
robert do you have a paid for house i
don't like
uh i do
wow robert you're amazing baby step
seven a teacher making 40k it is
possible christy you're amazing thank
you for calling thank you for showing
people that it can be done a teacher
forty thousand dollars a year incredibly
generous paid for house paid for college
debt free y'all
it can be done
regardless of your income regardless of
your position regardless of your stage
of life no you're not too old no you
don't make too little money you can make
this work if you're just willing to
commit and make some changes just like
robert did that is so cool robert you're
a rock star thanks for calling
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
i'm kristy wright george campbell and i
are hosting the ramsay show for you
today
it's friday it's a
halloween weekend and uh we're here to
answer your calls and hear your stories
i loved it just before the break robert
called in and had an awesome just
example of how he has done it on 40 000
a year as a teacher he's become
debt-free paid for college paid for his
house
this is why we do what we do is to hear
calls like that and inspire those of you
all that are on baby step one baby step
two or maybe just new to us and
considering for the first time hey
is it really possible
to live life without debt
is it really possible where i don't have
to live paycheck to paycheck is it
really possible to save up and pay cash
for a car
to pay off your house yeah it is
possible and we help people do this
every single day this is why we do what
we do this is the ramsey show so give us
a call triple eight eight two five five
two two five especially if you're new to
the show and you're like hey i keep
hearing these stories what does this
mean what am i supposed to do
what are the baby steps george and i
would love to talk to you give you some
encouragement to get you on your way and
then hopefully you'll be calling us in a
few years telling us your story just
like robert did and like so many people
do
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we're gonna go to
louisville kentucky with jason hey jason
how are you
hey guys i'm good how are you guys today
great what's going on
good good hey thanks so much for taking
my call and thanks for all that you guys
do sure thank you i have
i have been
uh kind of on and off the ramsey
journey for many years but i am finally
finally uh debt free awesome completely
free
and yeah it um thank you so much it's
it's taken a lot of uh uh stopping and
starting and and a lot of life happening
uh to finally get me to this place but
um and i'm super thankful and super
grateful for uh for being here um and my
question is this um i actually am um
going to be getting married um in the
next year sometime in the next year
um this is gonna be a second marriage uh
for myself and uh my fiance
and um she also is completely debt free
including her house
she's worked very hard
to get there as a school teacher similar
to the previous call actually yeah and
in just a really really good financial
position
as we go to get married um obviously our
lives are gonna combine with with no
debt um we will ultimately live in her
home
and my struggle is this i i guess maybe
i just need maybe some insight or some
encouragement or something here but
i'm struggling a little bit with the
idea that i
just am not uh going to be a major
contributor
to our deaf free life um we'll be moving
into her home it's about a half a
million dollar home that's paid for
um it lots of money saved i've got a
little bit saved as well but i'm just
struggling with the idea that um i'm
kind of stepping into a situation where
i
i don't really have to do anything
uh to to
to contribute to a
financially free life
and um
you know i've lived most of my life
sort of in conflict and trying to figure
out how to pay bills and all this and
that and finally getting to a place now
where i'm debt-free and
you know loving that
but just feeling like
i don't know it just it's a struggle for
me uh to step into
um a marriage
and be a beneficiary of all of her hard
work
um and i don't really contribute to that
and so i don't know it's it's a very
strange place in my life and i don't
know if you guys would have any insight
or thoughts to just kind of uh give me a
boost here with that yeah well thank you
for calling uh we'd love to talk through
this with you i have a question about
your fiance um
how how does she act about the money
piece of this with you is this something
that she is like um it's our money this
is our life or is just is this something
that in any way she holds it over your
head or is there anything that you feel
bad
because of her because of the way that
she treats it
no not at all um it's very much the the
first she
um
uh is
incredibly gracious and sweet and kind
and
um does not hold it over you know my
head at all
um
i'll be bringing a little bit more of a
of a savings account to our to our life
together
um but again you know
it doesn't really compare much to um
what she's done but no not at all i mean
there's there's no hanging over my head
whatsoever yeah um i think we're both
just equally excited to be able to have
a life together yeah um but i i think
it's more my struggle than hers for sure
jason
where is this coming from this level of
like this is a competition who's
bringing more to the marriage who's done
what financially
where does that stem from do you think
for you personally
you know i came out of a really bad
marriage um
and i i wouldn't
be shocked um if a therapist told me
that it stemmed from that
um
i i struggle with with that
a lot you know just the idea that there
is some level of of competition although
that sort of paints it in a little bit
of a negative light and i i don't feel
you know i don't really feel
the competition per se but it's just
um
i don't know i think as a man um as a
you know a provider it just is
it just is a struggle i i guess well and
i think you bring it up an interesting
point jason because even being from i
mean even living in kentucky like i live
in the south i've grown up in the south
there is a cultural thing to what you're
saying i think you can see that in
church too for people that are believers
so that whether it's spoken or unspoken
i can see that you feel this pressure to
your words be the provider and there's
different value systems and different uh
gosh there's lots of different stances
on that but the thing that i'm just
excited for you is i'm excited that you
have this new relationship you are
excited about the future your fiance is
excited about the future and you guys
are debt-free and set up really well
when you walk down the aisle it's going
to be we
we what are we going to do and it
becomes y'all's home together and it's
everything is about the future the past
is in the past and i know it's easy to
say that it may be something you do want
to dig into and and counseling that type
of thing we all have baggage we bring to
anything that we do
whether it's a second marriage or you
get married later in life or childhood
or whatever but i'm just um i will just
tell you from from an outsider's
perspective i think that all of the
things that can be right or right your
spouse is supportive you're coming into
a great situation you're bringing a lot
to the situation and i don't want you to
underestimate that um financially but
also just um you know from who you are
as a person we are a lot more than our
bank accounts and you will bring a lot
to the marriage that is more than your
bank account and so i just want to
encourage you i think that you have so
much to look forward to and i think that
if anything that guilt or shame or
whatever is something that can be worked
through and it's worth it to work
through it because i don't think you
need to live under that cloud i think
that you're in a great situation and
certainly there's nothing even to work
through on the side of your fiance where
it's some unhealthy dynamic of her
holding it over you um i think this is
probably like you said either from
wounds or the cultural pressure to be
some idea of what a man is or what a
husband is and i think that um you and
your fiance get to define what your
family is and you get to define what
your future is and i'm excited for you
jason i think that i think that you're
doing great and um and maybe it's worth
leaning into with like i said with some
some counseling to dig into that even
with your with your fiance and say hey
what do we believe about money and how
do we feel about this and and so on but
i think i think you're doing better than
you think you are yeah and christy this
all points to one thing that your worth
is not your net worth and i think as men
it's easy to tie your performance and
your income to how am i doing as a
husband as a father as a friend and when
you take all that away and you strip it
away and go no what does it mean to be a
great husband what does it mean to be on
a team with my wife as we step into this
amazing new chapter and guess what the
money part is really not a huge part of
the equation because of the financial
position that you guys have put
yourselves in remember you did a lot of
hard work you shared your debt-free
story with us and what it took to get
there
so don't step into this thing thinking
i'm not bringing anything to the table
you're bringing worth work ethic you're
bringing character you're bringing so
much more than just a number yeah yeah
and the and you and you also like you
said you also do have the finances you
have the savings account you have you
have both and uh and so i think what
we're just we just want to encourage you
that yes you're doing better than you
think you are and uh it's a great
question to ask i'm glad you called but
it's something i think you should lean
into i think you and your fiance can
walk through this together talk through
it together and it will bring you even
closer and by the way you all are in a
great position financially y'all are
doing great this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey listen whether you want to dream a
new dream tackle a new goal or just
manage your time more intentionally in
the new year i've got just the thing to
help you my new 2022 goal planner is
here it's like having me as your
personal coach to keep you motivated and
that's the truth y'all i wrote this like
a book there's content every month
there's tools and templates to help you
put into practice what i teach you for
the monthly themes there's journal
questions for reflection there's a month
in review at the end of each month so
you can reflect on what you learned and
what you want to do more of or less of
before you pile on the pressure of the
next month and then of course we've got
the calendars we've got your monthly
your weekly your to-do list there's
spots to write down what you're grateful
for write down what you're doing for
yourself your family your dream
this gives you what you need to do the
things you want to do and be the person
you want to be
and here's the thing i've told you this
before and it's not a joke they sell out
every year it's true every single year
and last year they sold out earlier
than any other year we did order more
this year but they are tracking like
crazy so if you want to get this as a
christmas gift for someone in your life
i would say go ahead and get it don't
wait until the christmas season because
it's going to be crazy shipping is nuts
right now and uh and you want to be sure
that you actually get it so go to
ramseysolutions.com
to get your 2022 goal planner today
that's
ramsaysolutions.com for real they sell
out and you don't want to miss out
george campbell and i are hosting the
ramsay show today for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're taking your calls so give us
a call we'd love to talk to you we're
going to go to washington dc with
michael hey michael how are you
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's going on
hey well first i want to say thanks me
and my wife got married a little over a
year ago we've been listening to your
stuff since then and using every dollar
and i think it's actually really helped
our marriage so thank you for that
awesome we love to hear that
yeah it's been a great jump start um but
i'll dive into the question so basically
both of us had a little bit of a scare
with our employment due to the vaccine
mandates
and it kind of caused us to reassess our
financial situation so
we do have a little bit of a savings
but we also have a car loan and a
federal student loan and
we were at first saving for a house so
we have about 65 grand
set aside for a down payment but now
we're wondering um should we
knock out the car loan uh just right now
get it out of the way really quick or
knock out part of the student loan
or is it better maybe to just pay the
minimum payments and then save the money
maybe for the next year or so and really
just build up our savings as much as
possible just in case
um i don't know something happens with
the economy or something else happens
with our employment
what do you guys think about that how
much total debt do you have including
the student loans car loans and any any
credit cards or anything else what's the
total
no no credit cards the total debt is
about 140. so it's about 130 for student
loans and 10 for the car gotcha and
what's y'all's income
230 000 oh y'all make a great income
michael y'all make a great job um are
you new to the ramsey show
um
uh i've been listening kind of on and
off for
probably i have for about two years and
then we started listening together like
i said about a year or so ago cool well
the the reason i ask is because a lot of
times some you know if people are new to
us or you know if you hear the show kind
of in bits and pieces it's easy to get
confused and maybe do the baby steps out
of order and you guys are that's what
y'all are doing you're kind of doing
things out of order with the house
savings and so on so i'm gonna let
george take it from here um but you guys
are in a position to make some good
changes but yeah we definitely want to
do things in a different order to set
you up for success yeah what i'm seeing
here on paper with your income and where
you guys are at you've just been trying
to do a lot of things at once and you're
not seeing the progress that you want to
see so if you've got 65 000 in cash i
know you guys want to get a house and
that's an awesome goal but right now
we've got different priorities we've got
to clean up this debt and so with that
65 000 i'm gonna take 64 of that if
you're doing the baby steps going back
to baby step one we've got a thousand
dollars and the rest we're gonna crush
the credit card debt in half of the
student loan debt just like that car
loan you mean yeah yeah the student loan
that's 130 and the car loan is 10. so
you clean up the car loan today and half
of the student loan debt today which is
amazing and then you get you make 230
000 a year the student loans are gone
under a year with your income if you
guys are getting intense about this
making some sacrifices once you've got
that then we can get that fully funded
emergency fund because i heard it in
your story you guys are a little worried
about the future uh but when you owe 140
000
you owe other people and so if something
goes down you're still stuck with those
payments and your income doesn't stay
with you and so i want you to clean up
this debt get that fully funded
emergency fund three to six months it
sounds like you guys should lean towards
six months because of your uh job
situations
and then that's when you'd start saving
up for a down payment and with that
income you're going to get back to that
65 in no time if you do this stuff in
order because all of the income is
focused on one thing at a time that is
what we teach that's how we see progress
every debt free screen you've seen they
followed those steps to get there and uh
you guys can do it you have an amazing
income and there is a pile of debt but
we can clean all this up real fast and
get you into a house in a few years the
the only other thing i would add to that
michael yeah because you guys are in
such a good position
to get this knocked out and cleaned up
really quick the only other thing i'll
add to that is it's really easy to be
tempted to make decisions based on fear
when it comes to job security and you
guys had a real scare for sure but when
you when you said things in your
questions like the economy and this and
the other we could we could run what-if
scenarios all day and it's just not
beneficial what we want to do is make
decisions based on facts the fact is
today you have a job if you can see that
you have a job for the foreseeable
future then we're going to operate as if
you have a job if for some reason you
got some notice that you're going to be
laid off in two months or there's going
to be some vaccine thing that affects
you guys being able to work there in
three months then yeah we would say okay
let's stockpile some cash and start
looking for another job asap but that's
just not the case from what i heard from
your scenario and so i just i i don't
want you to run what if scenarios i want
you to look at today in the foreseeable
future today we have jobs we have a
great income so we're going to work the
baby steps like normal and not get
caught up in those um what if scenarios
yeah you can clean this thing up it
won't take long honestly i mean you guys
you've got a big pile of cash and a
fantastic income we just got to start
doing things in order to see that
progress yeah and i know it feels a
little scary but i promise you we teach
it in this way because it works and once
you get into it you'll get motivated
you'll get that debt knocked out and
you'll be so glad you did and then you
won't feel that risk or fear even if you
lose job because you've got a fully
funded emergency fund all right let's go
to grand grand haven uh with david hey
david how are you
good how are you guys doing christy
george thanks for taking my call sir
what's going on
well a question about rock 401 k rock
iras um
my employer just recently made the roth
401k uh investment option at work
and i'm taking advantage of that along
with a company match but i'm wondering
uh if there's any benefit to
putting all of my 15 toward that uh raw
401k and
not funding the roth ira or what the
minuses are there
yeah absolutely it's a great question i
mean both are going to be great options
so we love both here at ramsay because
they grow tax-free which means if you've
got two million sitting in the roth
portion that's what you can take out uh
in retirement so i'll tell you what i
personally do because of that roth
option being available usually we tell
people hey go up to the match if you've
got one with your employer do you have a
match
we do yeah yep that's great uh beyond
that we say all right if you've got a
traditional 401k we're going to go fund
a roth ira first and then come back to
the traditional but but since you have
the roth you can do all 15 percent in
that roth 401k and that's what i
personally do here at ramsey we we do
have a match here at ramsey and i do 15
on top of the match
from my own funds into that roth 401k
and i let that grow tax-free so the ira
is a great option there are some income
limits with that and there are some
limits to what you can contribute to
that
other than that you can fund a
traditional ira if you are beyond that
income limit what's your income
uh 80 000 okay so you probably wouldn't
go to the limit of the roth 401k so i
would just make it my goal to make sure
i'm doing 15
of my paycheck on autopilot into that
roth 401k uh and later on in life if you
end up making more income you go past
the 401k limit then you can look into
other options like traditional iras and
and taxable investments but you're doing
great man that's a great question for
someone that's listening right now and
they're curious what is the limit do you
know george what the limit on the 401k
no to go uh yes no sorry the income
limit to be able to yes the chance if
you're single i believe it's um does
that change year over year
uh slightly okay every year the irs just
nudges it
give or take a few thousand but i
believe here if you're single then it's
got to be less than 125 000 gotcha and
that's helpful for combined probably
around 200 grand so you can check with
your tax pro and find out the irs limits
each year but around there you're good
so rot401k is a great option yeah it
makes it easy that's awesome it's good
for people to know the difference there
all right i want to thank producer james
childs associate producer austin and my
co-host
george campbell this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life and your money i'm christy
wright
author of the new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance and i'm joined today by my good
friend fellow ramsay personality and
host of the fine print podcast george
camel and we are taking your call so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five we love answering
your questions we love hearing your
stories
and uh if you've got a question about
money uh we were saying just in the last
hour maybe you've got a question about
the baby steps you're new to listening
to the ramsay show
and you're not even sure what the baby
steps are
or what step you're on or what step you
should be on uh we would love to walk
through that with you explain them why
they work and help you get started on
your path to becoming debt free and
finally controlling your money where you
don't have to live paycheck to paycheck
and uh and you have a lot less stress so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five and we're going
to kick off this hour in scranton
pennsylvania with mike hey mike how are
you
hi christy hi george great to speak to
you guys yeah great to talk to you
what's going on
uh question about open enrollment and my
employment is happening right now and if
i recall i i enrolled in fpu last year a
year and a half ago and
uh did they recommend not
or denying the like dental plan and the
vision plan just to help i'm trying to
cut back and save as much as i can so
i'm trying to save some money so that's
a great question i actually don't know
george yeah as a
what we teach here is that you can
self-insure when it comes to dental and
vision it's really it's usually not that
expensive and that's something that you
could you have an hsa what kind of uh
plan are you choosing this year
uh
you know it's i've been using the same
plan basically
as long as i'm employed but last year i
just i didn't take the dental and
there's and i was thinking about it
again this year because it's coming
around like oh what did dave say what
did they say so yeah what's that what's
the cost of that if you elected to
choose it what does it cost every month
for the premium i mean it doesn't seem
like it's a lot it might be like three
four five dollars per pay check so it
might be like you know six to twelve
dollars per month so as far as that's
like the dental plan thing but and what
does that cover exactly because i mean
if it's
three or five bucks yeah so when you do
the math on that and you go all right
i'm 12 bucks a month times 12 that's 150
bucks and what is that paying for
too clean for cleaning two cleaning
basically if i remember correctly it's
almost kind of a wash it's like it's
exact as if you would pay it cash if i
remember a lot of thoughts
yeah so if you've got some major health
issues teeth issues things of that
nature that's something that you can
look into is
getting that but at that rate if you're
just looking to get it for the cleanings
it may not be worth it and so we just
say hey take that 12
park it in your savings account and if
you've got an hsa health savings account
or you have a high deductible health
plan you can use something like that to
fund those things tax-free so those are
great options it sounds like you're not
in a high high deductible health plan
right now
no no i'm not i just have two kids
that's i'm a single dad with two boys
and you know some but uh and they also
have like a flexible spending plan but i
just i think that's ridiculous also
because you can if you don't use it you
can't
get it back anyway so i might as well
just keep the money in my own savings so
yeah we we tell people to self insure on
stuff like that so if i'm you i'm just
socking away money every month in a
sinking fund for those healthcare costs
for you and the kids and then pay for
that out of pocket when that comes time
yeah thanks for calling mike hope that
helps
all right we're gonna go to atlanta
georgia with christine hey christine how
are you
i'm doing well
thank you yeah thank you so much for
everything that you guys do you've been
a blessing to me this past year since
i've been listening to the podcast
awesome thanks for saying that what's
going on
yeah
so right now i'm i have to make
financial decision about sucking uh
selling my second uh property so this is
a property that i bought uh back in 2007
when i was first divorced from my
assessment
and um i have been renting it for the
past five
years but it's being wrestled to my
sister
so i'm in a predicament i'm completely
debt free i'm following the baby steps i
believe right now i'm on baby steps uh
four five and six
except for this step that i still have
on the second home
yeah so what was your reasoning for
selling the second home you said
i don't i don't want to sell it
that's that's sort of where i'm at
because my sister
christine can you speak directly under
the phone it's hard to hear you it
sounds like you might be driving it
sounds like the window's down or
something
okay sorry about that
there we go
all right where's christine
so basically what's happening is that
the second home is being rented um to my
sister and my sister's not right now in
a financial capacity to be able to
really
um afford a home and she has um you know
kids that are living there as well
so i don't want to sell the home i have
equity in the home it's worth um
230 000 if i was to sell it today and i
owe 86 000 on it and i've drastically
reduced the debt on the home
the past three years since i started my
baby step journey i paid it down about
thirty seven thousand dollars cool is
your primary residence paid for
no it is not um
my primary residence is about um it's
worth about 420
um but i owe 190 on that
okay and that's all of your debt is the
86 and the 190 on those properties
other than that i have
no debt no i paid off my credit cards i
paid off my car
um and you know i paid down as much as i
can out of the uh the you know the depth
on that second home in the past three
years since i've been following the baby
steps way to go of course so are you
charging your sister are you charging
your sister rent is she paying rent
right i am charging her rent yes she's
able to pay but it's pretty much yeah
she is able to pay that but it's the
equivalent of my mortgage payment
um it doesn't pay for the hoa dues so
that's something that i have to go ahead
and take on my own you're losing money
on this right now is what you're saying
i'm losing i'm losing money but it's not
a significant amount but then again
you know i'm trying to follow the baby
steps and i'm trying to make a decision
about what to do and whether i should
continue to eat at this cost or not
yeah this sounds like it's going to be a
hard conversation with your sister and
go hey i want this i want to be a
blessing for you and i want to be able
to provide this but here's my financial
situation and i'm losing money right now
as i rent this thing to you well and i
think i think the other thing is it
doesn't have to feel like this extreme
christine like you're kicking your
sister out on the street you could give
her a three month six month heads up and
it sounds like if you're really charging
her rent market rate rent and she can
pay rent then she can pay rent somewhere
else if the right thing for you to do
is to sell your house you can do it in a
way that is honoring to her that gives
her plenty of heads up um that this is
not the only place that she can live and
if you give her a good transition time
you know then then i think it will not
feel so abrupt to you or her but if this
is the right thing to do for you um then
like george said i think this is just a
hard conversation you have to have yeah
you think she'd be open to that
conversation and saying hey i want to
help you through this three-month
six-month transition period help you
find another place that's affordable
that you can make rent on would she be
open to that
i think she would be um i would have to
give her maybe more than six months on
because she's transitioning careers
right now um but yeah
well it all started with go ahead
yes this would definitely set me up to
maybe pay down my uh home mortgage you
know my first range on the house that
i'm living in right now
and um and be able to start investing
and putting more into my 401k because
right now i can only afford eight
percent yeah you're you're gonna get
there
i think it just starts with a
conversation it may go better than you
think and it may actually even be easier
than you think and she may transition
faster than you think starts with just
having a conversation but i know you can
do it thanks for calling christine this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and 6 gigs
of data with no contract the average
family saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we're on a
mission to transform so many lives that
disruption spreads like wildfire what
does that mean well just imagine a world
where it is weird to have a student loan
instead of everyone assuming that's the
only way to get an education
imagine a world where it's normal to pay
cash for your car
imagine a world where credit cards are
the cigarette of the financial industry
now imagine being a part of the team
that's making all that a reality through
the work you do every day
at rmc solutions we have a thousand
people working together to create
digital products and services that will
transform people's lives our goal is to
disrupt the toxic money culture that
exists in america today
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for
developers or if you're a ux designer or
seo and content marketing specialist
we'd love to talk with you
found find out about all the available
jobs by texting work to 33789
text work work to 33789 to find out
about all of our open opportunities it
has been so cool george to see some of
the
people joining our team because you
really do have people that are joining
the team that have a story very we we
don't hire people that are vanilla you
know that kind of like i don't know i
need a job it's like you are not for us
we are on a mission and we're looking
for people to be on that mission and uh
that that creates a really powerful
culture here here inside these walls
where people are actually passionate and
excited
imagine that they actually care about
the outcome they actually want to make
it better and and uh yeah it's a really
it's a powerful
ripple effect from the fact that we're
on this crusade that affects our hiring
it affects the culture it affects the
team dynamics it affects the passion of
course the quality of the output so um i
love that we are looking for more people
like that that's work text work to
33789 george campbell and i are hosting
the ramsey show for you today give us a
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five
and we are going to take your calls
we're gonna answer your questions so
let's go to lexington kentucky with
angela hey angela how are you
hi i'm ben how are you guys good what's
going on
um so i was calling to
kind of
pick your brain about because you do all
the business stuff and i know it's more
centered
towards women but i figured you could
help me um
my husband does seasonal work and he's a
um
like moses and landscaping and so it's
calling to see
how best was saved for his seasonal
business
and a little background i was a
stay-at-home mom
after getting out of the medical field
and
and then we ended up pregnant and so i
went to work part-time at a restaurant
until the baby was born then was
stay-at-home mom um and then when he
started his business i went back to work
in june or july
and
um
so his
moment is over for the season this week
like this is the last week unless he has
any confidence the grass is just
you know extra healthy and grows um
so
my whole paycheck is going to save for
his
business but my concern is
having to use any of it for
sales if he doesn't get a job
prior to next month's bills coming in
yes okay when you say your entire
paycheck goes to save for his business
what is that money going to
it's going into a savings account and
just a regular savings not anything with
interest accruing or anything like that
but we have to have all of his equipment
because we're out of debt um we're i
guess on baby step three because we only
have our
thousand dollars saved since we're
saving for the business
um and we don't really have any extreme
expenses we
live with his mom
and um she owns the house so we don't
have rent or anything like that just the
utilities and things
and
and so it just my whole paycheck goes
into the savings what are you saving for
though what are you saving for what are
you saving for
in his business is there a particular
piece of equipment that he needs before
next summer is what are we saying
yeah so he bought some equipment for
this season um in march
um but he just bought stuff to get him
started and it's not gonna you know be
sufficient for next season especially
with him wanting to grow his business
and
so
there's a particular brand of mower that
he wants it's um skag and so it's like
um pretty much top of the line everybody
has their take about what type of mower
and so he's done lots of research and
that's kind of how much money does this
business bring in per year
um
i don't know because
where i work and then try to homeschool
and then have the baby i was working
with him for a little bit in the
beginning before so what's the household
income what's your what's your all
y'all's household on income together
and so i make 15 an hour
um and then his really depends because
he doesn't have like a
full-time help um so it depends on who's
helping him and
kind of how experienced they are based
on what they say here's what i'm getting
at does he need a top-of-the-line mower
if this is kind of a fledgling business
that's trying to get off no no i can
answer that for you george no he doesn't
i'm gonna be i'm gonna channel my inner
dave ramsey angela listen let me tell
you what i'm hearing you've done ryle
christie he's got a business that's not
making money and he's funding his
business with your paycheck at the
expense of y'all's family expenses so
that he can have a big fancy mower no
does that sum it up no we're not gonna
do that
and we need to separate these finances
the business needs to fund the business
the profits
from his mowing this summer needs to
fund the savings for that equipment now
if you want to live on your paycheck
that's fine if you want to have a goal
if he wants to have a goal a trajectory
of saying okay i'm going to build up the
business this much and we want to
supplement it in the short term but at
some point this business needs to stand
on its own and the business needs to be
supporting you
not you supporting the business we've
got this flip-flopped right now
go ahead i apologize if it came across
that way no so his business was
supporting us okay so the perfect yeah
so his business was
um you know paying bills and all of that
and plus supply and any other
uh business expenses that he had so um
employee payroll gas and um
like
whatever expenses for the mowers and
things like that that he needed or any
equipment during this season that he
needed gotcha
my my paycheck is solely to pay for new
equipment for next season but it's not
going to be like brand new fresh off the
market type deal we're looking on
facebook
so my question was just
how best to go about saving for that and
and
um
i guess looking out and marketplace and
things for the best deals yes we got a
great deal on a truck
um low original miles it needed a mower
we got a great deal on a low mile mower
and a mechanic to do it
for a great deal and so the truck
um
it was is going to be less than 6 000
total all in
um and you guys are cash flowing all
this
yes we are cash flowing it that's why i
was calling because that's my um kind of
my question is like
i guess
maybe i've ordered it wrong i'm not no
no you're doing great but we're running
out of time so let me give you your
answer angela i think this is going to
sum it up yes he needs to look for a job
in the offseason he can also look find
ways to use his skills in the interim
season so leaves people gonna need a lot
of leaves in the next you're in
lexington there's leaves lots of leaves
in lexington he can look at using his
skills as equipment for leaves for that
season which would buy you a couple
months probably you can also do seeding
all that type of stuff in the fall
there's lots of things he can do that
are not just uh lawn mowing that's one
way to do to buy some time he should
look for a job in the off season the
other thing is in the future i want the
business to support the savings for the
business where the business funds the
business in addition to your household
expenses your paycheck goes to your
expenses we're just going to separate
those for tax purposes for peace of mind
you can actually have a report card of
how the business is actually doing and
then um in addition to that he can save
from the business during the summer in
order to support him in the off season
so the the main takeaway i want you to
have is the business needs to fund all
of this business funds future equipment
purchases business funds your life and
expenses business funds savings for the
off season and when the business starts
to do that then you have a real
profitable business it's fine if your
savings is boosting it in the interim
but i want to go to where we flip this
the business is supporting you and that
paycheck that you have is going to your
household it's going to make life a lot
easier but yes he can get a job and you
guys just save next summer for that next
off season so we're not in this position
next fall but thanks for thanks for
calling you can do it just going to take
a little work
[Music]
[Music]
all right this is one of my most
favorite parts of the show where george
and i get to talk to people that have
become debt free and we have daryl and
artesia on our debt-free stage welcome
guys thank you thank you for having us
thanks for being here this is so
exciting so i'm guessing this means you
are debt free that's right we're
different oh my gosh congratulations
okay let's get the story here how much
debt was it it was 93 000 550 well
ninety three thousand five hundred fifty
five dollars and sixteen cents we're not
missing that 16 cents daryl
all right and uh how long did this take
you two and a half years okay
and what was your range of income during
that time we went from 130 000 to 170
000. nice
nice job what do you guys do for a
living so i am a salesforce
administrator and i'm a mental health
therapist awesome oh cool great careers
and where you guys from
so you want to get this yeah we're from
memphis originally we moved here to
middle tennessee for school and after
school we moved to dallas texas so we've
been in texas for almost two years now
awesome where'd y'all go to school here
in nashville we went to middle tennessee
state university cool awesome okay so
take us back two and a half years ago
y'all were 93 000 in debt roughly what
happened that changed her life changed
her plans
so
i was forced to get to my will
i can't wait to get this part of the
story yeah so um basically i had been
following the ramsay teachings for years
at this point um back in 2015 i did rain
total money makeover but i never really
took that jump on to get motivated and
it was before we were married but i used
to actually in a car make her listen to
the rambling show uh just kind of like
that's right
youtube people see it the radio
listeners aren't seeing that eye roll
that's a strong eye roll there i'm here
for it yeah but uh once we dig in uh
start got engaged we went through
marriage counseling through our church
with pastor james mccarriel in mercenary
at first baptist and
he gave us our gifted us fpu um and then
we went through lpu that kind of gave us
the jump in the start to actually start
and do it the right way okay awesome
okay artesia let's have it what was this
like from your experience
of not being excited about this yeah i
was not excited i don't think i got
excited until
we went through fpu okay because then i
could really see it it wasn't just my
boyfriend at the time telling me hey
we've got to do this there's this guy
dave ramsey and he says we can pay off
our student loans and i'm like what yeah
there's no way we can pay off student
loans um but once we sat down and i
think it was the first budget that we
did
and of course i'm adding all this cool
stuff onto the budget that
we had to eventually take off
but that first budget gave me that boost
of okay we're bringing in a nice amount
of money maybe we can pay this off but
it's going to take more than a few years
is what he was telling me it's going to
just be a few years but it ended up
being two and a half years there you go
okay how long have y'all been married
this is our third year married okay
awesome awesome what kind of debt was
this
so it was student loans credit cards and
cars
a little bit of everything a little bit
yeah
yeah wow and was it pretty split between
you two or was it heavily weighted it
was it was actually pretty even
okay that's good so you both had some
skin in the game here yo we got to clean
this mess up yeah i got a question for
you daryl so you you said you had read
the total money makeover before okay
what was different for you from reading
total money makeover to going through
financial peace university how is the
experience different i think this time i
had an accountability partner yeah um so
i had and i also had all these um
different people my ear um and also a
fraternity brother they kind of was just
guiding me and saying this is something
that you should do okay um it can set
you up for life that's cool we hear a
lot of people's stories and they
intersect our our path on on different
different ways some it's total money
makeover some it's financial peace
university some just listens to the show
it's always like hearing especially
since you kind of had both of those what
that experience was like all right so uh
two and a half years ago you guys decide
to pay it off we've got a plan we've got
the years uh what was that process like
in terms of making those budgets and
making the sacrifices and y'all are
getting married in the process of all
this
yeah it was rough yeah
especially in the beginning very
transparent it was rough yeah i think in
the beginning well i know in the
beginning we used to kind of put heads
about what we wanted on the budget what
we thought was important um because
pampering is important i was like that's
important why can't i keep this it was
the hardest thing to cut out of the
budget where he was like no we got to
cut this i'm sorry for me it was gift
giving i'm the oldest of four so i'm
used to taking care of my siblings
christmas birthdays all of that like i
did it big yeah but when we started
doing this process he's like okay i
don't care who it is we're going to have
to put a cap on the amount that we get
for gifts and i was like everybody gets
the same amount do you put a cap on love
daryl do you have you yes
so that was the hardest hardest part and
then giving up travel those experiences
of travel that was really really
difficult yeah wow let me go out on limb
here and guess that you are the free
spirit or tasha yes
i can relate i can relate all right so
who were your biggest cheerleaders
through this whole process i know you
mentioned a couple people there who else
we're cheering you guys on yeah so we
had our parents of course um we had
siblings as well
um and i have a list too that's great
so
while he's pulling that list up i'll go
ahead and mention um we have a couple of
our church members over here um beside
us that's rudeness on they were
cheerleaders for us um through financial
peace university in the christian
excellence ministry at our church at
first baptist wow wow that's awesome
that's huge that accountability piece
and having people in the corner and you
guys had everyone in your corner you
could get it normalizes what most people
think is crazy you mean you're going to
live without credit cards it's like when
you get people around you and you're
like okay i'm not that crazy i mean i am
but at least these people it's we're all
the same kind of crazy right yeah
we still had that too we had a few
people tell us oh that's not our
interest we'll let you do it we'll let
you handle this though right even after
we paid off the debt they're like oh
that's good for you yeah you do you yeah
yeah and you never know because they may
be coming around in a few years and wait
a minute can you tell me more about that
absolutely it might might just be a
light for them what was the um what
would you guys say is the key there's a
lot of pieces to the puzzle but if you
were to boil it down to one thing like
man this makes the difference to getting
out of debt
i think for me it was a mindset shift so
i'm remembering that anyone can do it if
you follow the steps anyone can do it it
doesn't matter your demographics where
you come from it doesn't matter if you
follow the steps um and take on that
education that you're receiving through
the program anyone can do it so changing
that mindset of what does uh financial
freedom look like and then put yourself
there yeah anyone can do it that's
powerful that's powerful it starts with
just believing that it's possible if you
don't believe it's possible you won't
try and do the work and you guys did all
right y'all you're debt-free how does it
feel feels great it was amazing
i didn't think it was possible but we
did it yeah i think he still kind of
doesn't feel real to us right now yeah
yeah and now here you are and listen
christmas is around the corner you can
travel again at some point you can you
know give those gifts and have yourself
care days or tasia that's awesome you
guys have worked so so so hard for it
all right well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey because that is
definitely the next stage in your
chapter and your story we've got a copy
of the total money makeover maybe give
it to some of those people that say good
for you and be like hey just in case you
ever want to come around it could be
good for you too that's right cross on
over and uh and we are just so proud of
you guys and so so so excited for you so
excited about um what's going to happen
next because you've done this hard work
all right
we have got daryl and artesia from
dallas texas paid off ninety three
thousand five hundred fifty dollars and
sixteen cents in two and a half years
making 130 to 170 000 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and they're so cute if you're listening
on the radio you can't see that they
have denim jackets on which is just i
love a denim jacket i can't believe i'm
not wearing it today i wear a denim
jacket at least a couple times a week
yeah can't go wrong with that what an
inspiring young couple more of that on
fun friday i'm here for it way to go
darren artesia incredible oh my gosh and
it's just it's really fun to hear how
everybody's um
the way that everyone gets to the baby
steps might be different you know maybe
a friend maybe financial peace
university maybe a marriage counselor
maybe maybe a threat you can't marry my
daughter unless you go through this
class i've heard that it's always a fun
one
it's gonna be a good family uh you know
or a total money makeover live event
back in the day or
um you know facebook posts so there's so
many different ways that people might be
introduced to this concept
of living debt-free which is weird out
there in the real world but we are out
on a mission to normalize it where
people can live
with no payments yes and daryl and
artesia are doing it they could levitate
they're so free and light right now they
are proof that it can be done
oh that's amazing we'll be back very
soon this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell and i are hosting the
ramsay show for you today triple eight
eight two five
five two two five if you have a question
for us we are here for you we're gonna
go to irvine california with jacob on
the line hey jacob how are you
hey i'm doing really well how are you
guys great what's going on
so um
i'm recently married uh we just had the
wedding that we've been planning for a
long time with coving congratulations
everything
thank you um everything went
perfectly well we're very very pleased
uh but
financially we kind of spilled
everything we had into it
the budget was kind of thrown out the
window uh
probably three four months closing to
the date uh but everything went fine we
have debt that we need to address
um and we're renting in irvine
california and ultimately in a year or
two we want to try and purchase a home
we'd be first-time home buyers
so
um we've kind of got a big
chore ahead of us
um
so i wanted to ask once we really jump
on all the debt get that out get all
that out of the way
um
what what what's your guys advice for a
first-time homebuyer in california
particularly now because the climate is
just
it just does not seem
stable yeah just inflation everything
that's been going on in the news
and value property values out here are
just so high yeah
and we're kind of anchored by family so
i've already tried to make the argument
uh we should probably leave the state
buy a home somewhere else because it'd
be easier for us to do
but um
we're kind of anchored here by family on
both sides so we're not going anywhere
anytime soon gotcha okay um how much
debt do you have jacob to combined
so we're at like 35 000.
okay that's both that's everything
credit card student loans everything
yeah i uh i can't really take credit
anymore but i mean now that we're
married i took on her debt willingly i
love my wife but uh she she went away to
school for a little bit changed her mind
um so we've got like about 25 000
student loans from her and then the rest
is like credit cards
and what jaws household income combined
uh we're
very very fortunate we're doing really
well we're about a hundred to 110 000
okay great that is not as bad as i
thought jacob when you said you just had
a wedding where you threw the budget out
the window i like i got he was really
getting over selling this i was like oh
no this is this is bad and it's not that
bad jacob it's not that bad
that's what we're telling ourselves but
we don't want to be complacent so
that's good no i'm glad i like that
you're asking and like that you see it
that way that you're that you're focused
on getting out of debt and i like that
you're i like that you're taking that
approach so george walk them through the
baby steps so cure the order of this
what is driving this one to two year
timeline to get a house
so it's just the fact that if we're
going to save 10
for a home out here it's going to be 50
grand or more coupled with the 35 000
that we need to take care of so we need
to save 85 000
in what time frame and based on kind of
how we're living
uh and renting and we hate renting
because we're literally burning our
money
i'm getting nothing for it uh that's
just kind of what it looks like well
you're gonna have to actually save more
than that jacob
yeah so what i'm hearing is there's a
little bit of this impatience of like
well there's inflation and california is
expensive and you know we're married now
we have a good income so we should be
able to get a house right
that's what i thought well
uh here's the thing i think renting
right now you're not burning money
you're buying patients uh you guys are a
newlywed couple there's nothing driving
you to have to get a house
and right now we've got to clean up this
debt and as you know you said hey we
need to pay off this debt which
hopefully you're going to do first right
yes that's the plan and then there's a
piece missing here where you need to
have a fully funded emergency fund how
much money do you guys have in cash in
savings right now
uh around
two thousand we're paying rent at the
end of this month like we literally just
landed two weeks ago from the wedding uh
paying off vendors finalizing all that
kind of stuff and we really just burned
we burned
everything like any kind of personal
savings we had merged with our wedding
savings account so wow a lot a lot of
burning going on
okay yeah that's how we were left with
you're basically just starting on baby
step two now which is cool so this is
the dead snowball and so you only have
two debts is it a credit card and
the 25k on the student loans
yes both our cars are paid off um we pay
rent but other than that yeah credit
cards and then student loans okay so we
are going to attack this credit card
with a vengeance we're going to make
minimum payments on everything except
for that smallest balance we're going to
list them in order from smallest to
largest ignoring the interest rate i
know it sounds crazy and we're going to
attack it and with your income if you
guys get focused you can get rid of this
debt within within a year easily does
that sound right yeah your time yeah
absolutely i'm thinking six months i
love it hopefully and then with that
other year and a half you're hoping to
save up you know 50 grand for a 10 down
on on a half million dollar condo i
assume in your area
uh at least some kind of townhome uh the
area if we're going to be realistic and
we're going to buy something that
you know is
a relatively new property
in the area where we're at it's probably
going to be in excess of 600 650
650 okay and that's kind of and that's
kind of on the low end so realistically
if we wanted a down payment and she's
told me because she's been looking too
and we have friends that are realtors
and first-time homebuyers they get you
know they get benefits and oh boy maybe
we'll only have to put down three point
five but yeah i'm more real no no we're
gonna change we're gonna change those
numbers you called the wrong guy man you
asked me for what the parameters are for
a newlywed couple first-time home buyers
don't fall for these programs man
there's all kinds of built-in traps in
here and one of the biggest traps is
putting as little down as you can that's
not what we want to do here we want you
guys to be financially free so here's
what i want you to do
15-year fixed-rate mortgage with a down
payment of 10 percent minimum ideally 20
to help you avoid private mortgage
insurance which is just protecting the
lender not you so that's an extra few
hundred dollars that you're throwing
away if you don't like throwing away
money now just wait till you have pmi
and you're a homeowner you're gonna be
spending money all kinds of places so 10
to 20 down 15-year fixed-rate mortgage
and at that point uh you want to make
sure the payment is no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay
so start doing the math running the
numbers we've got a great mortgage
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and
here's what that means it might mean you
know what
two years from now we can only afford a
place that's 400 grand and a year after
that we can afford a place that's 500
grand and so you might say hey we need
to wait because we really want this
place that's 650 and that's more of a
four-year time horizon and then you've
got to be okay renting and realizing
that's buying you patience and it's
setting you up for financial success
down the road and the thing that i want
to point out jacob is when we give you
advice that is what we teach here from
ramsey solutions on how to buy a home
the right way we have absolutely no skin
in the game on whether or not you do it
it does not benefit us if you buy a 300
000 home or a three million dollar home
it doesn't benefit us anyway whether or
not you get into payments up to your
eyeballs that you can't afford where
your house poor and you can't even eat
anything or you don't and so i just want
you to know that our advice to you is
for your benefit we're not getting any
commission off of any programs that
we're pitching you and so the reason
that this is so important is because i
want you to learn from how this feels
coming home from the wedding which i'm
sure it was a fantastic wedding it was
also
one day that you spent a bunch of money
on it sounds like more money than you
wanted to and so what uh george is
walking through here are the baby steps
that is the best way to buy a home first
a thousand dollar savings you guys have
that you have an excess of it so take
that other thousand put on your debt
second list all your debts smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
attack that small debt begin to pay
those off as quick as possible just like
we said then you're gonna save three to
six months of expenses for any emergency
that might occur because i guarantee you
being a homeowner is full of emergencies
you didn't plan on like air conditioning
goes out or whatever
and then above and beyond that you're
going to save your 10 to 20 percent for
a down payment so we're looking at a
longer time line than you expect and
probably a smaller
house budget that than you expect but
you called asking for advice and this is
it and if you do this
you are going to look up and be in such
a better position financially you're
going to be able to afford the payments
you're not going to be throwing away
hundreds of thousand dollars in interest
and you're going to have a 15-year
mortgage that you're probably going to
pay off earlier than that and so that's
the reason that we teach what we teach
but i want you to stay on the line
you're newlywed let's uh give you a year
to ramsay plus
take the class in there called financial
peace university watch the video lessons
with your spouse that will give you even
more in-depth advice on how to follow
the baby steps and how to buy your first
home when you're ready thanks for
calling and congratulations on getting
married i know you can do it all right i
want to thank producer james child
associate producer austin selby and my
co-host george campbell and you america
for listening this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm kristy wright and joining me
today is my good friend host of the fine
print podcast george campbell and we are
taking your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you have a
question about money
about the baby steps about what you
should do next maybe making an important
financial decision we've had a lot of
calls today about buying houses and
things like that newlyweds and how to
get on the same page and combine your
savings and so on give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we would love to talk to you christy i
had an epiphany ooh let's have it the
last hour i realized as we're telling
people what to do that it's really hard
to hear and then i realized if the
advice is hard to hear it's probably the
right advice oh you mean like
emotionally hard not like the volumes
down yes okay emotionally hard i was
like george do i need to help show you
where the volume button is in your
headphones oh i know that part but it's
just such an epiphany if the advice
feels good yeah and you go yeah that's
oh yeah that feels really nice then it's
probably not the right advice and so a
lot of the things we do on this show
we tell you things that you may not want
to hear
but you kind of called because you kind
of needed to hear that
yeah yeah and we and we're good at that
we're good at telling you the tough love
truth
the kick in the pants
the truth that's going to get you to
where you want to be even though it's
it's not fun to hear that's a good point
no and but sometimes here's the thing
it's not a theory to us not only have we
lived it personally and so we believe it
very deeply but we get a front row seat
to see other people live it out when we
go oh my gosh look if you do it this way
it works every time yeah and so a lot of
people go well chris you don't
understand my situation i don't make
enough money or we live in a high cost
of living area or we've got a lot going
on right now we've got kids and when you
take out all the excuses and
justifications at the end of the day
this framework works for anyone yeah
anyone and we're seeing people at all
income levels ages stages of life
different family dynamics different uh
industries that they work in and so on
and um and yeah it can work for you
even you and so if you have a question
about how to do that give us call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george i
was given this article
about a week ago i guess and this is in
nbc news and i thought it was really
interesting because it is so
in line with what i teach in my new book
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance and i wanna i wanna set
this up by asking you a question because
i think this will be a fun discussion
for us
you know one of the things i hear all
the time is i just need more time i just
need more time and the reality is we
don't need more time if you had more
time you just fill it with more crap and
you'd still end up tired so it's not the
answer but we do have this this belief
that we just need more time
so there's a new study that came out on
the sweet spot of the right amount of
free time so i just want to ask you what
do you think the right amount of free
time yes this will be if i had to put a
number on it without reading anything
i'm going to say per night what are we
talking just per per day in life like
like no
no restraints okay no money's not an
object money's not i'm going to go three
hours
not george is that outrageous no i just
don't think you would really you really
think only three hours people would want
if they didn't have to work they didn't
have to do anything
i think beyond three hours i'm gonna
form some terrible habits there's gonna
be a lot of netflix binging george
ahead
that's how i know these things here's my
breaking news that george is
illustrating so beautifully apparently
there's such a thing as too much free
time
there's such a thing as
too much free time leading to overall
unhappiness and i think we have this
idea that i just need more free time if
i just had all the time in the world man
that'd be the best i could do all the
things i want to do wouldn't have to do
these things so here's the the study
this is from nbcnews.com a new study
finds that people
did
and it says as the amount extends beyond
that the benefits
decline at around seven hours the extra
free time and i'm quoting here
the extra free time starts making people
feel bad
according to the study and it says this
the more interesting thing is that
having too much free time is also
associated with lower levels of
well-being and happiness
now this is really interesting because
the entire
premise of my book and i obviously read
this after i published my book but
the entire premise of my book is
redefining life balance my favorite
thing that people say is this is not
just another time management book and
you're right the goal was to reclaim
this word redefine it and shine light in
a space that is very saturated and say
something new in the conversation so i
define life balance in my book as this
life balance is not doing everything for
an equal amount of time it's about doing
the right things at the right time and
when you do the right things at the
right time you actually feel that sense
of balance that you've been looking for
all along and i go on to define
balance as having peace in your life
even if it's a little crazy being
confident your choices being happy and
proud of how you spend your time
so there are four things that get in the
way of us doing the right things the
right time this is in uh in my chapter
on redefining balance this is chapter
one and i want to read this because
there's four reasons number one we're
doing too many things that's the most
obvious
number two i think is less obvious
number two we're not doing enough things
now someone might experience this if
they're an empty nester or they um
are newly retired they've maybe lost a
sense of their identity with their work
and retirement or changing jobs or or
something or we all felt this last year
in the pandemic at first we loved all
this free time and then after a few
weeks we were bored and and feeling out
of balance and so the way that i say
this in my book take back your time is
if you don't have people to connect with
and responsibilities to show up for and
outlets to share your gifts with or
projects to plug into you're going to
feel bored and out of balance
so these are the first two of the four
causes of being out of balance number
one you're doing too many things number
two you're not doing enough things and
then i go on say number three you're
doing the wrong things and number four
you're not doing the right things but i
think it's so interesting because
there's another quote from this article
in nbc it says
it says of course simply having a lot of
free time isn't necessarily harmful
especially if people are happy with the
amount of time they have and how it's
spent they're saying the same things
spending your time on what matters to
you
then it's not so much about the hours
it's about you're spending your life on
what happens to you 21 000 people took
the survey y'all and i just thought that
was so fascinating there may be a lot of
you listening going too much free time
there's no such thing
but i think it's just a good reminder
that the solution is not necessarily
more time the solution is not
necessarily oh we've gotta um you know
quit my job and and go meditate for a
year no like it's just doing the right
things at the right time and when you do
the right things the right time and
guess what
you get to decide what's right for you
so if what's right for you is training
for the olympics or staying home with
your kids or pursuing a hobby or working
like crazy to build your business or
taking time off you could decide what's
right for you but when you do the right
things the right time you feel that
sense of balance you've been looking for
and it turns out balance really is just
being proud of how you spend your time
yeah being happy with how you spend your
life so all this research basically
supports your now best-selling book take
back so validated and i must say
christie you felt so validated you were
reading from page 17 and you were
already dropping mics that early
most people are just writing the intro
you're like no we're going hard page 17
let's go i just thought that was so
fascinating i did i read this and i was
like oh
it's it's i feel so validated yeah three
and a half hours all right that's so
much free time i'm gonna have this
tonight and you are a very good guesser
if i have to phone a friend on a trivia
show i'm calling you guys
you know things george you know things
it was surprising to me not to you
oh this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend george camel he is the
host of the fine print podcast which
comes out every two weeks on different
topics to shine a light on the things
that are holding you back
with your money the fine print the stuff
you probably don't know about so you can
check that out wherever you listen to
podcasts and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we're gonna go to sacramento
california with mia hey mia how are you
hi chrissy so glad to connect with you
girl you need to check your dms on
instagram no
i sent you a message mia listen i
literally i get so overwhelmed by dms
george do you answer all your dm's i try
to but here's the thing christy you're
way more popular like i get like one dm
a week you get like a thousands a day so
give her some grace mia i feel like that
we should contact instagram to make it
less clunky of the approval process i
got so many problems with me instagrams
dms anyway i'm here for you mia what's
up how can i help okay so pandemic um
out of boredom and working at home i
created body butter because my son has
eczema okay and so i've created this
body butter and i'm like a society thing
now and um
friends family is buying it 20 bucks a
jar
and they start telling their friends so
now it's kind of snowballing into this
thing and i want to know how to make it
a thing um
and um it's taken off and i'm kind of
scared
to kind of just launch myself because i
don't think i can fulfill those much
that many orders so how do i connect
with something or something that math
produces this how do i market this
um
i'm yeah that's what i need and i would
like to george go to school but if we
get to that we get to that okay well
i'll keep it somewhat short so you can
get to the question with with george if
you want to but here's here's the thing
me i think you just need to identify
what specifically you need done so are
you just saying the actual production of
the body butter like you have a recipe
and you need this to be duplicated at a
mass quantity
yes okay
so there's
the best way to go about it and this
sounds so scrappy but the best way to go
about it is just start doing some
research if there are other people
producing body butter in your area or
lotions or creams or anything like that
to find out who they use
i'll i'll tell you a great solution here
in a minute that i'm going to get to but
just getting scrappy doing research
asking around and so on is a very good
first step because then once you have
let's say 5-10 contacts of people that
do this type of work then you can get
quotes and get samples and make sure
it's going to be true to your quality
true to the scent true to the packaging
all the things that you want to do so it
starts by truly just asking around but
if you'll stay on the line i would love
to give you a membership to my coaching
group called the business boutique
academy it's not open right now but
we'll give you a spot we just opened a
few weeks ago so you'll be kicking off
the next six months with us and the
reason i say that is is not only do i
talk about scaling in my training
lessons me inside the academy but also
um that community is so powerful for
getting specific
vendors and resources and so you can
post in our private facebook group hey i
want to produce this body butter to my
scale and there's tons of women that
produce creams body butters lotions that
can immediately respond and say hey
here's the types of people i use here's
a contact call this person ask for this
quote so it will just um they'll come
alongside you and make that super easy
but yeah what question do you have for
george about school because i feel like
that'd be the academy is going to be a
great place for you to scale this and
they'll come alongside you and help you
do that
thank you so much in virtual hugs okay
george um want to go to cyber security
school
starts december 6th it cost 12 000
um i'm debt-free i talked to you and
john delaney about a month ago who i was
scared to pull the trigger and pay my
last debt so i did yeah awesome
congratulations um
so i and i have my
i have six months of emergency fund this
is my method i have twelve thousand
dollars um and six of it could be
my deals are twenty two hundred dollars
per month so if i use 6 000 to put
towards a 12 and do monthly payments
um for six months because the booth camp
is for six months
is that okay
or should i
what should i do what's the deal with
these monthly payments is this
is there interest on this is this a
program to the school no there is no
interest on it it's directly to the
school they'll let me do a payment plan
um the payment plan would be a thousand
down and two thousand per month for six
months but i can't afford that so what i
was going to do is put six down and then
a thousand dollars per month i can
afford that and the latest that would be
yeah and they'll let me do that
interesting or i could finance it for 24
months interest rates no no okay so
you've got 12 000 and that's your
emergency fund and you're saying hey i
can go down to three months
you take half of that to pay for this
program
yes and you're wanting is this something
you're wanting to do full-time cyber
security
yes i want to go to cyber security i've
been a social worker for 24 years so i'm
ready to move change careers and so um
is this the best option for cyber
security training is this super legit is
this in your area is it online have you
researched all the options for that
yes it's online six months three days a
week after work from 6 30 to 9 30. um
yeah so i mean i've researched that part
i've also researched other boot camps um
and it's it's this is supposed to be
like
the number one that everyone is going to
okay and what's what's driving the
urgency of hey i've got to get in on
this december 6th training is there one
six months from now
it is but right now i work from home and
i'm pretty sure in 2022 they're going to
start making us go hybrid and that's
going to make me lose my opportunity
um
because
what i do is i fight i travel so right
now i'm not traveling because of kogit
so i'm like steve's the moment oh so
right now you can do it all remotely do
this whole program
and if you do it later on you may have
to be in person partially
well i'm gonna have to be back at work
in person
okay and i'm not gonna be able to yeah
well i don't love the idea of you
depleting the emergency fund and doing
this thing on on payments i would want
to be reading the fine print on what
this this program is with the down
payment and then making payments on this
thing um because it kind of feels like
debt at that point if you've got monthly
payments to make but i understand you're
cash flowing the program as you're going
through it so look into that but also if
you can get this side hustle really
rolling the next two months as the
holidays roll in maybe you can make a
few extra grand and be able to cash flow
a bigger portion of this well i was
going to jump in and ask that if you
could do your side business full-time
mia would you want to
oh god yeah okay yeah well
yeah i mean because you asked that
question first i wouldn't immediately go
to that but because you asked that first
i would give that a chance if i were you
you you really don't have the funds to
do this this program right now unless
like george said you get it from your
side business but i would just challenge
you there's a possibility that if you
were to put this on hold and say i'm
gonna give six months let me walk with
you for six months in my in my coaching
group called the academy six months
there are women making seven figures in
this coaching group there are women
making a hundred thousand dollars in
their first year in this coaching group
you can do this if you just get a little
help and support now if you don't want
to i'm not going to try to point you
towards the business if you don't want
to but if you want to the opportunity is
there and we can help you do that before
you go pay 12 grand for a different
career option does that make sense
yeah yeah i'm just changing the cyber
security because there's like it's a
good you know good income and i want to
make i want to make but if i could make
body butter for a living that wouldn't
even be worse so you're not really
passionate about cyber security but you
see it as an opportunity you want to
make more money
yes listen let me tell you something i'm
putting pause on this cyber security
training there's no there's no cap when
you're in business for yourself mia and
i know that feels like a pipe dream
right now because you just made some
cream and thought it was cute and then
people liked it but women are absolutely
building massively successful businesses
and you can define your version of
success we can grow this to whatever you
want it to be
but i think i think you need to give it
a chance i think that the combination of
the fact that you want to change careers
you want to make more money you don't
have the money for cyber security and
your business and your words is taken
off
let's let this thing take off let's let
it take off and see what it can do and
scale it and get some some better
operations and production around it and
uh you might be doing this thing full
time in a year and you didn't even ever
see that coming saved yourself 12 grand
and you're doing what you love
full time imagine that that'd be pretty
cool stay on the line austin will get
you hooked up with a membership to the
business boutique academy which is my
coaching group and uh let's see let's
see what we can do that'll be so fun
look at that christy she didn't even
need to dm you she just talked to you
for eight minutes way better so fun this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well i don't want to let you i don't
want you to let your valuable time pass
you by your time is like your money once
it's gone it's gone
in fact you can get more of anything in
life except your time you can get more
money you can't get more time
and if you try to
do everything all the time you're going
to feel exhausted
out of balance and you're probably going
to fall off the wagon on your goals
y'all we see this happening every single
year we start out the year with good
intentions we've got the goals we want
to make changes we want to get debt free
we want to lose weight we want to you
know have more time for the things that
are matter most to us and we set goals
around those things and then
by march
we have
lost sight of those goals at best
and probably feeling guilty and beating
ourselves up for not staying on on track
you know more often and so
the all of this around goals and the
guilt we have and the frustration we
have is exactly why i created my 2022
goal planner
this is the tool to help you stick with
your goals and that doesn't mean i'm
going to be making you feel bad in july
if you're not doing what you set out to
do in january but i do help you reassess
so in may i say hey the seasons are
changing look back at those goals from
january do they still make sense do you
need to change some parts of them did
you already achieve some of them do you
need to add new ones reset move the
timeline this is a very
practical
goal setting tool to help you focus on
the areas of your life that are most
important to you from your spirit mind
body relationships resources managing
your time managing your money balancing
it all all of those things
and i give you the tools and templates
to help you put what you're learning
into practice in addition to putting
your goals on calendar so this is a very
very
intentional
tool it's not just a calendar you can
buy calendars anywhere this is a goal
setting tool to where your goals get
translated to your calendar which is the
system you manage your time by
you can get your copy of my 2022 goal
planner at
ramseysolutions.com today and
go ahead and get it if you want it or if
you want it as a gift or you want to buy
a few as a gift go ahead and get them
because they always sell out every
single year
last year they sold out at the beginning
of december and people were emailing me
late december early january asking if we
would order more and because it's dated
and because we obviously have a delay in
what we can produce and print we don't
reorder them we do the best guess that
we can on the quantity at the beginning
of the year we don't reorder so if you
want one go ahead and get it they will
sell out no we will not order more
but we got some right now so go ahead
and get them if you want one for you or
someone as a gift that's ramsey
solutions.com the 2022 gold planner by
me christy right all right we are taking
your calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five george campbell and i
are here for you and we're gonna go to
victoria british columbia with josh hey
josh how are you
i'm doing good how are you doing today
good what's going on
can you hear me all right yeah you sound
great what's up
awesome uh so i'm 21 and i make just
over 100 000 right now and sort of on
track to
be doubling that within a few years and
at my age i find that like
my my girlfriends brothers friends and
such they're not necessarily at the same
place as me uh with with their finances
and
whenever we go out and do things i find
that sometimes i get anxious about maybe
where they're at financially or is what
i'm asking them to go do things is that
going to inflate their lifestyle because
like i know what it took for me to get
where i am and i don't necessarily want
to
be the the influence that's making them
spend more money than they can and for
me i'm more than happy to pay for them
and
be able to take them on trips when i
want to go do things with them because
for me spending time with them is more
important than than thinking about the
thousand dollars or a couple hundred
dollars that it takes to take them out
and do that i just don't want i want to
make sure that i'm not um
i don't want to be putting them down
anyway by making them feel like they
don't have the money to do that and i
also don't want
um i don't necessarily want to
inflate their lifestyle to a point where
then they're
if for some reason i don't pay for a
trip then they're going into debt
because they have never learned to save
for that yeah i wanted to have any tips
on how to sort of navigate that yeah
well first of all i want to commend you
on a couple things number one you're
making a killer income at a very young
age so way to go
second of all i love just how
considerate you are josh the fact that
you're asking this question shows what
just a good guy you are you're looking
out for your friends from a financial
standpoint but also from just their
feelings and how they feel about things
which is really really cool um that's
that's really really impressive a couple
things i would say and george you hop in
here but here's just off the top of my
head
number one i would definitely make you
paying for them
the exception not the rule because if it
becomes a pattern then you start to feel
pressure too and then there's this weird
dynamic where they expect it then that's
gonna put a real weird dynamic on your
friendship that you don't want so i
would say default to everybody pays for
their own thing
and um and when you ask them to do
something you can say up front like hey
guys i was thinking about do this what
do y'all think and if they say like i
don't have the money right now whatever
cool you can back off
or um if they do then they're grown ups
and you can't be responsible for their
financial choices because you invited
them to a party and they made a bad
decision to attend you're not managing
their bank accounts so let's start with
a clear boundary there
but when you do pay for something i
would throw in one piece of advice here
when you do pay for something i would
try to pay for it as
discreetly as possible and again this is
the exception not the rule so let's say
for example um you guys are all out to
dinner and you just want to pay for the
dinner and drinks and stuff you might
you know go to the restroom grab the
server and say hey here's my card let me
cover this and when the server comes
back they're like what happened i just
wanted to get it this was fun and don't
make a thing of it if you make a thing
of it then it becomes this thing like
you're the guy that pays for the things
and then it tilts the room of like
you're the guy that like is paying for
everything and yeah extra bottles of
wine on on josh it doesn't have to be
like that like i would just i would
handle it super discreetly when you do
it which is a really cool move that you
are a generous guy and willing to do
that but i think that's just going to
protect the friendship so that they
don't feel
in debt to you if it's the exception not
the rule and when you do it you do it
discreetly that's that's what came to
mind for me george what would you add no
that's spot on and on top of that i
would just say having that community
that line of communication where you're
saying hey what what is the budget what
can you guys afford i'm happy to to
match that so that we can make this
happen i think that's awesome but
there's also a lot of things you can do
that don't cost a lot of money so don't
always make it a thing where hey we're
taking big lavish trips big lavish
dinners make it just a chill thing where
we all split some pizzas and they pay
their fair share uh because i think that
gives them dignity i think that's what
you're worried about you don't want to
take away their dignity and be showy and
they all of a sudden go wow this guy is
he's really something and he wants us to
know it and i think that's where
christie's heart is as far as the kind
of the discreetly doing this stuff and
my brother's that way he's super
generous and he's always the guy that
sneaks over and gets the server pays for
it and we're all like whoa dude what
what the heck he's like i just you know
just makes city yeah it makes it easy
don't just put the bill yeah he's just a
super sweet generous guy and i feel like
that's your heart josh what i don't want
it to come across as is pride yeah
whereas just look at me and i feel your
heart behind that you don't want it to
be that way so find things that are
cheap that don't cost a lot of money and
do that stuff too yeah i think if you
have a good mix of that if you have a
good mix of um cheap stuff that
everybody contributes to
maybe some some nicer things that
everybody contributes to and then every
now and then you get the tab on
something or or even if let's say it was
a concert or something and you knew
everybody was free everybody wanted to
go and you're like hey guys i was able
to get tickets let's go and then it's
not this weird thing of like them
watching you pay for it it's a big show
i think just the more under the radar
that you can keep that that transaction
that will maintain some of their dignity
but you still get to do what you want to
do which is be generous and you still
get to be with your friends and share
with them and they get to participate in
some of that stuff but man josh you're
an awesome guy you're a really awesome
guy thanks for calling thanks for
thinking of your friends and and
thinking of how that would affect them
and um and yeah i think that if you do
it that way it will come across in the
right way but just know that when if you
got in the habit of just paying for
things all the time it does tilt the
room and and that's not what you want so
i love george's advice of just do some
stuff that they can afford hey what's
the budget you know when when me and all
my friends we're grown women but when we
get together to go on a girls trip we'll
say like where do we want to stay what's
the budget because regardless of your
income level you should have a budget
and you should have a plan for your
money and so it's a great way to open up
the conversation where they get to speak
into it and you guys can plan that event
or that hour i saw recently this guy had
a spreadsheet and him and his friends
they have very different incomes some
are broke some make hundreds of
thousands of dollars and they have a
spreadsheet and it shows what your
budget is for these trips who can make
what and there's no judgment
there's none of this like well you make
this we're going on a bougie trip they
just go all right i'm broke i'm not
going on that trip yeah that's it yeah
and they have fun with it so i thought
that was a cool idea yeah transparency
and communication that's good
great call thanks for calling josh
thanks for your question thanks for
looking out for your friends this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
deuteronomy 33 12 says let the beloved
of the lord rest secure in him for he
shields him all day long
and the one the lord loves rests between
his shoulders
brian tracy said the glue that holds all
relationships together is trust and
trust is based on integrity
that is the truth all right find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
jenny in texas i have a very specialized
business that i've been doing as a side
gig for about three years
i already have my clients but i want to
start doing this full time so i will
need to double or triple my client base
is it worth hiring an outside source to
be able to get this off the ground so i
can quit my day job that i hate
this is interesting george when we get
questions like this granted it's on a
piece of paper it's for blinds.com but i
just have so many follow-up questions
i'm curious what the very specialized
business is but i'll tell you my gut
answer is no
you can build this business up on the
side on your own now for a season it
might feel like that you are working two
full-time jobs because you are
but the idea is that it's just a season
and once that side business is built up
so much that it can support you then you
can take the step not leap step to
working on that business full time and
here's the interesting thing that i want
to remind you all anyone listening right
now that is working on a side business
and you would like to do that business
full-time just like i was talking to mia
with the body butter she was talking
about wanting to build up the side
business possibly doing it full-time
the side business does not have to make
the equivalent of what you're making in
your full-time job now
it just needs to make the amount of
money that you can live on
so if you make sixty thousand dollars
right now in your full-time job
and you can build up your side business
in uh jenny's question here in
blinds.com from texas mia's example
anybody's example you build it up let's
say to thirty thousand dollars and you
can make some cuts in your budget and
and temporarily live on less then you
could take that step to working on your
business full-time now and then of
course once you dedicate full-time time
to it then you're hopefully only going
to increase that income but i don't
think you need an outside source um
jenny i mean
you could hire a salesperson on
commission if you want to i just don't
think you need it and i think that's
more headache than it's worth when you
are a solopreneur right now trying to
relay your dream to another person
that's the hardest thing georgian
business the very hardest hire is your
first hire and so if you're hiring
someone and it's still a side business
for you and you're only able to dedicate
so many hours to it man that just feels
like that's going to be a lot of
training because now you're leading
another person that takes time too
that's time you could just be spending
on getting the clients yourself and
you've got to pay them so that's taking
out the profits from the business that
you're trying to grow right now to get
this thing full time so it doesn't seem
like a great idea i lean towards no
jenny i lean towards no on the hiring
someone um an outside source as you said
i'm assuming that's what you're talking
about there build it up yourself on the
side and it's gonna be a little crazy
for a little bit but again it just needs
to be the amount of money that you can
live on and um and then you can make
that step not a leap a step all right
let's go to paul in riverside california
hey paul how are you
hi
hey what's going on
so right now i'm in escrow on the house
um
purchase price is 5.85
i sold my house so i have to be out of
here
tomorrow we're moving out
and uh we're gonna get to this other
house next week
so we're gonna stay at my mother's law
mother-in-law for a week
uh but it turns out this house is uh
a little bit more than what we were
hoping to pay
so they quoted us
around 2 600 a month for our 30-year
mortgage
and it came back that there's some
special taxes on the house
and some model rules and stuff so
payments the new payments 2900 a month
what's your take home
uh
between 80 and 90.
80 90 000 a year
yeah is what you take home and that and
that quote you said is based on a
30-year mortgage
yeah 30-year mortgage
well uh
you said you're in escrow right now
actually sorry
what'd you say
the 80 and 90 that's uh my gross income
so your take home is a lot less than
that then
yeah
we're probably talking 60 take home if
you're talking about five grand a month
is what ends up in your bank account
uh i think about 6 500
a month 5 500 a month and this mortgage
payment on a 30 year
is that i mean it's taking up 50 of your
income on a 30-year mortgage you guys
are going to be drowning in this thing
this is this is a no paul
what can you do instead
how do you get out of this thing
i'm not sure that's why
i was thinking we stayed with my
mother-in-law that she has a two-bedroom
apartment and there's
me my wife and my two kids
but even at 2600 this thing was was way
out of your budget
without the special taxes
yeah we're looking for 25 of take-home
pay on a 15-year fixed rate so this is
way way way out
i think you guys are not ready to um
get a house right now i mean it sounds
like unless you can stay at the
mother-in-law's for a while until you
find something that you can afford do
you guys have any other debt
uh i got about 2500 and credit cards i
can pay that off yeah
yeah
so
do you have any savings yeah
well i made money on the on my house
that i just sold
yes okay how much did you make on that
about 170.
okay so where is that money going was
that going as a down payment on this new
one
so about 1 30 was going to the dom
payment
and the other 40.
um
okay for like your fully funded
emergency fund
yeah paul i think we got to slow down
here um and wait until this thing makes
sense for our budget and for our life
because i can feel the anxiety already
of what this is going to do to you guys
and so i think you need to back out of
this thing take a pause rent stay with
family do what you need to do until
number one you get all this debt cleaned
up all the consumer debt we have a fully
funded emergency fund and then whatever
money's left over that's going to become
our down payment we're going to keep
building that up and i want you to do a
15-year fixed rate with a payment that's
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay and i want you to have a good solid
down payment of 10 to 20 or more that's
what's going to give you guys some peace
well it sounds like you're going to have
that with the the money you just made on
this house with the savings and the um
being able to pay off the debt like you
said i think this starts with a
conversation with your mother-in-law
and just seeing what does this time
frame look like and do you guys rent for
a little while because you don't want to
rush a home purchase it's not this house
we know that you can't afford this house
which is fine
but so that you don't rush and make a
desperate decision which desperate
decisions are almost always bad
decisions i would suggest you guys
staying with the in-laws maybe
short-term very short-term finding
something to rent until you can find the
right house that you can afford under
the parameters that george just gave you
15-year fixed rate and and that so
whatever your payment is is going to be
less than 25 of your take-home pay after
you've put that down payment you just
said and you keep your fully funded
emergency fund with your
of debt paid off so you've got the
ability to do that we just still don't
want to rush into a home purchase just
because you can and it's definitely not
this house yeah and paul i don't want to
crush your dreams here so i want you to
do is keep dreaming but work towards
that dream and you can jump onto our
mortgage calculator ramseysolutions.com
and starts to play around with the
numbers and say hey what would it take
for us to do this the right way so
that's a blessing and not a curse so
that we're not house poor so that we're
not pouring all of our income into this
house that is probably going to have
more repairs and more problems and more
taxes and all of these things are going
to crunch your budget even further
because remember we have other goals we
need to save for college save for
retirement pay off the house early do
all kinds of things so that we can
retire with dignity so do it the right
way don't put yourself in this position
yeah um paul i think the and i know you
said the mother-in-law's place is small
but i would just encourage you to start
working now today on finding somewhere
to rent somewhere that you can afford
with your kids with your family in the
interim until you find the right house
and i think you will and you'll be
happier with where you end up because
you didn't rush it and you certainly
didn't get yourself into a situation
with the house that you can't afford
that is just going to absolutely
eat up everything they have where you
can't make any decisions you have no
margin so um yeah have a conversation
with in-laws find a place to rent and
then when you're ready you will find the
right house and um and you'll be really
glad you waited when people rush george
it always almost always messes things up
don't rush dave ramsey says this all the
time it's the tortoise and the hare we
want to be the tortoise slow and steady
wins the race every single time
all right i want to thank producer james
childs associate producer kelly daniel
and austin selby who is on the phones
today my co-host george camel and you
america for listening this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you